bem do meu espaço de jornalista começou
com uma pergunta de que todo jornalista
de alguma forma é um curioso
profissional né a gente tenha se esse
ímpeto e transformar afirmações em
perguntas né então se a curiosidade move
o mundo que a minha reflexão inicial foi
onde nasci essa curiosidade que nos move
é bom e queria começar também
compartilhando com vocês dois episódios
recentes da minha vida e eu digo que
mais do que pensar sobre o que aconteceu
lá atrás eu gosto muito de pensar sobre
essas coisas que acontecem o tempo
inteiro nas nossas vidas e que de alguma
forma mostra pra gente que a gente está
no caminho certo e que faz todo sentido
seguir adiante
então resolvi compartilhar episódios
recentes com o primeiro deles aconteceu
exatamente um mês atrás
no final de semana e essa minha
curiosidade de jornalista me fez cair de
gaiata uma história muito inspirador é
muito interessante bom naquele final de
semana
alguns brasileiros resolveram se reunir
num espaço ali numa cidade chamada são
francisco xavier e esses brasileiros ele
tinha alguma coisa em comum que é o
seguinte eu não tinha inclusive eles
todos já tinham passado por algum curso
na schumacher college uma escola de uma
escola é tida hoje como um dos
principais pólos de estudos e práticas
de sustentabilidade do mundo começou há
algumas décadas atrás e fica ali lá
perto de londres no interior da
inglaterra
eles resolveram se reunir aqui porque
todo mundo sente a falta né
londres a inglaterra muito longe e como
é que a gente faz para acessar esse
espaço porque a experiência que eles
tiveram a ferramenta transformadora e
eles resolveram se reunir mas muitos
sábios eles esperam seguinte não adianta
a gente importar uma forma não adianta a
gente trazer querer trazer a metodologia
da escola pra cá então o que a gente
pode fazer a gente pode se reunir
a gente pode dar alguns deixar um espaço
aberto para que a gente juntos
tem se como é que a gente pode criar
algo aqui no brasil
o que de alguma forma traga tem esse
mesmo espírito né mas trazer essa forma
importado já que tem lá não vai
acontecer
bom o que aconteceu olha o clima do
lugar que a gente estava ali eu cheguei
lá e aconteceu comigo algo que eu chamo
de tempo espaço de qualidade eu acessei
esse tempo espaço de qualidade
eu estava ali em meio à natureza no
lugar incrível compartilhando com
pessoas que tinham valores muito comuns
aos meus
todo mundo estava com má intenção mas os
estímulos eram abertos ou seja ninguém
estava ali para então vamos desenhar um
plano de ação para como a gente vai
fazer isso acontecer aqui e as conversas
eram muito significativas por conta de
tudo isso e aí qual foi o efeito disso
senti uma conexão profunda comigo ali
naquele tempo o espaço de qualidade e
também com as outras pessoas que estavam
ali e aquilo me deu uma vitalidade
estava tão cansada naquela semana e ao
mesmo tempo aquilo foi me dando um
prazer enorme eu me senti muito muito
viva ali né e com uma vontade enorme de
realizar
eu fiquei extremamente produtiva eu
quase não fui passar um final de semana
tinha muita coisa para fazer na hora que
eu cheguei lá eu conseguir fazer tudo o
que tinha que fazer só nos intervalos
nos momentos de excelente de coisa que a
gente tinha naquele momento
é uma experiência que assim um dia
equivale a quase um mês nessa sensação
que tinha de sair daqueles dois dias ele
era como se eu tivesse passado uma
eternidade foi muito gostoso
bom quem sabe o que aconteceu lá e se
explica um pouco porque eu vim
compartilhar com vocês
depois de um dia lá no momento eu sentei
debaixo daquela janela ele ó serra na
sala a gente ficava eu desenhei essa
conversa
pensei no convite que me fizeram de
estar aqui e simplesmente as coisas
foram num free fall brait e assim
comecei a escrever naquele cadelinha
tudo que eu queria compartilhar com
vocês
era como se a minha vida inteira tivesse
passado assim um segundo
foram uns 15 minutos eu montei é isso
aqui bom isso que aconteceu comigo já
tem muita gente estudando esse fenômeno
é o que alguns acadêmicos cientistas
estão chamando de flow que é o flor é
quando a gente está tão presente naquele
momento é quando a gente se coloca num
estado de conforto tão grande que
simplesmente as coisas acontecem e o
resultado daquilo
o que você faz quando você está neste
momento de flow ele geralmente
surpreende
ele está acima das expectativas então
você é um momento em que você mesmo se
surpreende consigo mesmo
você exerce um potencial você vai ser
rápido atendido e isso responde um pouco
à pergunta inicial né onde nossa
curiosidade talvez a curiosidade em
controlar a gente fazer o que eu posso
controlar a curiosidade mas talvez a
gente possa sugestionar talvez a gente
possa freqüentar nos colocar em tempos
espaços de qualidade que nos faz mover
uma energia que brota de uma forma muito
especial
bom um segundo episódio que eu queria
compartilhar com vocês e não foi tão
recente o mesmo foi bem recebido e três
meses
é eu fui pra diana é uma cidadezinha que
fica ali entre brasília e goiânia
leia a diana é mora vive e desenvolve um
trabalho é um dos principais goleiros do
mundo quem conhece joão de deus aqui
porque as pessoas também
vocês já tiveram lá em abadiânia bom
interessante porque quando cheguei lá
tinha mais gente do mundo inteiro
gringos enfim espanhóis a gente do mundo
inteiro e poucos brasileiros e foi super
curioso também e que acontece lá esse
remédio é tido como algumas pessoas o
maior médium vivo hoje na terra
ele atende 3 mil pessoas por semana
pessoas com assim com as maiores
dificuldades mas também tem pessoas lá
que vão pra simplesmente estarem ali
ajudando os outros também
então é um espaço que reúne pessoas com
intenções diferentes e quando estava lá
isso aqui me surpreendeu ao game
enquanto você espera para ser atendido e
fica assim mais ou menos como estamos
aqui sentados e tem alguém que fica
conversando com a gente fazendo
palestras explicando que acontece ali
contudo as pesquisas científicas que
estão tentando provar esses mistérios
que acontecem ali e aquilo me chocou um
pouquinho porque o joão de deus
constatou que 8 pessoas só buscam aquele
espaço por amor e 92% por dores na hora
que eu olho isso eu tiro do contexto do
joão de deus e pensa um pouco na minha
vida nas nossas vidas
nossa sociedade atual eu olho pra isso
falo caramba
qual o percentual de amor e de dor
o quanto eu me movo por dor eo quanto eu
me movo por amor e eu entendi ali ele
conseguiu explicar um pouco o porque que
eu venho fazendo as coisas que eu venho
fazendo porque eu acho que as duas
coisas acontecem ea gente se move por
sofrimento a gente se move por pressão
por precaução mas a gente também tem que
arriscar
isso também acontece o que me assusta
tão desigual mas eu acho que isso também
é fato porque a gente vem transacionando
nós somos as gerações que estão
protagonista anos protagonizando a
transição da cultura de guerra para
cultura de paz
isso é bem difícil se não é trivial né
uma coisa que justifica muito essa nossa
cultura um pouco ainda da mentalidade né
que não é essa mentalidade de paz
isso aqui virar lizhou muito na internet
é um pôster zinho interessante e acho
que todo mundo de alguma forma acredita
nisso que assim existe a nossa zona de
conforto ea mágica da vida acontece fora
da nossa zona de conforto
só que já tem gente estudando existe uma
mágica incrível que acontece bem dentro
da nossa zona de conforto
quando a gente olha para o nosso talento
para nossas habilidades da nossa força
de vontade a gente combina essas três
coisas a gente consegue atingir
resultados incríveis
bom alguém já ouviu falar da psicologia
positiva psicologia do positivo
a psicologia tradicional é muito mais
antiga psicologia do positivo década de
90 mas o dia tradicional surgiu pra pra
explicar e para cuidar das doenças da
mente
a psicologia positiva vem no caminho
oposto para complementar a dizer olha é
a psicologia da saúde da prevenção e
psicologia trabalhos talentos
habilidades ea força de vontade é a
psicologia que quer fazer a mágica
acontecer dentro da nossa zona de
conforto bom e dentro dos das pesquisas
da psicologia positiva em um dado que é
super curioso gente isso apesar de pouca
gente ainda conhecer as aulas de
psicologia positiva de harvard são as
mais concorridas
já faz uns dois três anos que elas são
as mais concorridas são mais ou menos
mil estudantes por semana e freqüentando
as aulas
então isso é um bom sinal o meu filho
bom eles essas pesquisas da psicologia
positiva mostrar onde eles chegaram no
que eles chamam da fórmula da felicidade
né
e olha que curioso e chegaram com um
estudo com mais ou menos 5 mil gêmeos
eles chegaram que 50% genético depois eu
não vou me alongar nisso aqui porque
senão a gente pode ficar o dia inteiro
conversando mas 10% é relativa condições
e condições nas quais a gente geralmente
acredita que são as maiores dos maiores
fatores de felicidade que são por
exemplo quando a gente ganha é esse a
gente é solteiro casado
se a gente emagreceu 20 quilos na
verdade isso representa 10% e os 40% são
atitudes intencionais para fazer um
paralelo com o que estava falando antes
é a somatória dos momentos de flow que a
gente consegue na nossa vida
então depende muito da gente olha aqui
40% está na nossa mão trabalhando
talentos habilidades gente consegue
levar esse número aí um potencial em um
segundo professor que é o dan gilbert
aula dele é mais popular de harvard
nesse momento escreveu um livro chamado
tropeçando na felicidade né
ele disse que é um conceito muito
curioso que a felicidade sintetizada a
gente pode olhar por sintetizada por
reduzida
ele fez um estudo curiosíssimo que diz o
seguinte é ele analisou pessoas que
tinham passado por situações extremas na
vida então alguém que ganhou na loteria
e tem uma situação muito boa e alguém
que se tornou um tetraplégico um
acidente e sabe que ele percebeu que
depois de um ano dois anos o nível de
felicidade dessas duas pessoas era
igualzinho
e aí que ele foi se aprofundar nessa
história é que ele chegou ea gente tem
essa capacidade de se adaptar às coisas
e que só que isso é perigoso ele não
disse isso pra gente parar por aí a
pergunta aberta dele é a seguinte a
felicidade sintetizada ou se é assim a
gente ao invés de arriscar ser muito
feliz
a gente aceita aquilo que a gente sabe
que a gente pode conseguir
se acha que a gente pode conseguir para
que a gente não corra o risco de ser
infeliz e aí a gente está reduzindo bom
e essa história da felicidade
ela tá ganhando corpo né é essa
cientistas de harvard também elas usa
nível c é uma monja budista
ela começou ela é que dar um novo nome
para todos esses estudos na psicologia
positiva felicidade sintetizado em um
monte de coisas
ela está achando da nova ciência da
idônea e que ela entendeu ela viu por
exemplo cigarro que aqui que o gráfico
que compara o nível de crescimento da
sociedade americana em termos de pib nos
últimos 50 anos o nível de felicidade
tanto que ela chegou à conclusão de que
até um certo ponto o dinheiro não traz
felicidade depois disso não mais não é a
lipton e ela participou do time que fez
a implementação do fib em oposição ao
pib que é o índice de felicidade interna
bruta eu acho que a gente tem que
entender a felicidade com uma prática
ela não sei mais aquela coisa super
aspiracional que a gente não consegue
alcançar sobretudo porque a gente não
consegue dizer o que ela é
se a gente entender ela com uma prática
devemos pensar na felicidade com uma
qualidade que podemos desenvolver assim
como a tolerância e empatia um pratica a
felicidade
isso já está acontecendo esse livro foi
escrito pela americana chamada grátis em
breve bem ela está assim no topo também
das palestrantes internacionais falando
sobre projeto que ela fez durante um ano
ela se propôs a desenhar o projeto de
felicidade dela e aí no primeiro mês
ela resolveu classes base a ela resolveu
se fazia isso há certos livros então
fazer o armário e esvaziou a agenda dela
esvaziou foi praticamente estação que é
uma maneira dela esvaziar a mente então
isso aqui que aconteceu no projeto dela
ela foi acumulando essas tarefas então o
segundo mês ela fazia o platinense
proposto no primeiro mês e no segundo
mês no terceiro uma fazia tudo por um
ano ela praticou a felicidade nas suas
mais diversas dimensões vale a pena dar
uma olhada nesse site ela traz o teto
kit assim de como fazer então tá cheio
de gente querendo começar a praticar bom
isso nossa aqui tá muito mais próximo do
que a gente pode imaginar né
e aí eu falo um pouquinho de contexto
é o seguinte o japão ele está no topo do
ranking dos países mais infelizes do
mundo pode parecer curioso mas é ele tem
um fenômeno lá eu não sei pronunciar
direito se tiver algum japonesa que ele
ajude por favor da ré para o chicago che
é um as pessoas relatam morrendo de
tanto trabalhar e ele está acontecendo
tanto que eles até criaram um termo eles
têm um tipo de terror diferente para
essas pessoas só eles morrem ali no
metrô na rua c sentados
isso é muito muito muito enfim maior
mexida quando falo sobre isso mas o
curioso também a gente vive num mundo de
contrastes né então lá no japão também
tem uma ilha chamada okinawa que é uma
das ilhas onde moram as pessoas mais
velhas do mundo na cidade 60 e poucos
anos e super felizes e aqui eles
atribuem essa felicidade eles atribuem
esse esse que ele chama de moncho o
mundo que é nós somos uma grande família
a ilha inteira é uma grande família uma
grande comunidade ea gente se ajuda
um cuida da saúde do outro cuida do
filho do outro isso eles acham eles
mesmos em foi perguntado para ele eles
acham que isso é a fórmula da felicidade
de eliza que leva eles terem uma
longevidade e aí isso aqui é uma
pesquisa né
sobre a felicidade também os nossos
objetivos que estão fora da gente né os
que mais são os vilões e os que mais nos
atrapalham na busca da felicidade são a
busca por dinheiro por imagem e por
popularidade e dentre os objetivos
pessoais na internos nos intrínsecos o
quanto mais a gente busca evolução
pessoal sentido de querer ajudar e senso
de comunidade
quanto mais próxima a gente consegue
chegar de felicidade ea e senso de
comunidade está grafado porque realmente
parece que os estudos estão chegando
hoje no nosso contexto nesta sociedade
que a gente vive cheia dos seus
contrastes parece que o atributo maior
que pode nos aproximar mais da gente ter
esse e se essa dádiva né de de viver
mais por amor do que por dor é o senso
de comunidade e aí tem um professor que
diz o seguinte eu gosto muito ele fala
assim olha talvez seja senso de
comunidade porque vivem em comunidade
nos focar naquilo que temos para
compartilhar
mais do que naquilo que a gente não tem
a gente tem alguma coisa que nossa mente
fica focado em algo que é muito positivo
o oposto disso a adaptação hedônica que
assim essa tendência é que a gente tem
que se acostumar com tudo o que a gente
conquista e que a gente perde o
interesse muito rápido ea gente entra
nesse ciclo vicioso de querer sempre
mais
a gente conhece um pouquinho bom esse
levou a dinamarca essa coisa voltando um
pouco no senso de comunidade o tal do
senso de comunidade compartilhar confiar
no outro lealdade cozinhar juntos fazer
as coisas juntos levou à dinamarca para
o topo do ranking do país mais feliz do
mundo e curiosamente eles são o país que
mais tem como house do mundo com house é
quando as pessoas compartilham o mesmo
na mesma casa né
mas passa e aí parece que bate com
aquilo que a gente quer é e aí é que eu
digo assim que as pessoas me perguntam
mas o que é a boa notícia boa notícia
fala de sustentabilidade eu acho que
pode até ser mas não é isso não é só
isso né
a boa notícia vem dentro desse contexto
todo dessa nossa busca de transição na
de uma cultura de guerra para uma
cultura de paz
numa cultura em que a gente fica olhando
muito para os nossos defeitos e fica da
um dever e uma cultura que a gente vai
valorizar um pouco mais os nossos
talentos nossas atividades com muita
disciplina para a gente poder ir adiante
a gente está mais em não cair numa
mediocridade então eu diria que a banda
tivesse aquela que tem foco na solução
no que constroem e construir não é fácil
eu queria fazer um exercício muito
rapidinho que é o seguinte não pensar em
quanto tempo a gente leva para construir
um prédio em quanto tempo a gente leva
hoje para destruir é muito expressivo a
gente tem que fazer juntos a gente tem
que trabalhar junto a gente tem que
estar muito disposto com muita
vitalidade pra construir esse novo que a
gente quer
bom eu acho que quem critica muito não
tem energia para construir um novo não
tem aquele viral também fala que em
trabalha muito não tem tempo de ganhar
dinheiro
mais ou menos a mesma lógica né então
por que a gente acha que as boas-novas
fala depois notícia junto a um monte de
soluções no mesmo lugar
faz sentido hoje em dia ressentido
porque a gente está precisando
os construtores porque a gente quer
resgatar o amor como motor da
transformação e porque o resultado disso
pode ir muito além da resolução dos
problemas porque afinal a gente quer um
futuro sustentável um futuro feliz
sustentável pra mim é um ciclo ele se
completa
a felicidade é um ciclo com pré completo
e sempre abertas pra gente se expressar
pra gente e ali e esse futuro que não
apenas a gente não quer é uma realidade
que a gente esteja simplesmente curtindo
reprimindo responsabilidade mas a gente
quer essa realidade e ultra a alma e eu
ouvi essa frase uma vez que me estimula
muito que se não é divertido não é
sustentável
e essa curiosidade baseada no amor que
todos nós temos conosco e que nos vai
pressionar o mundo para melhor é isso
que a gente quer é a boa notícia a gente
é que a felicidade é contagiante quanto
mais a gente tem mas todo mundo tem
em um estudo que diz que se 10% da
população do mundo conseguiu expandir um
pouquinho a consciência
a gente passa todo mundo junto para um
estágio mais elevado de consciência e eu
queria terminar se bem que acho que não
vai dar pra terminar trouxe um vídeo que
eu não vou botar porque acabei meu tempo
mas acho legal vocês procurarem
anteontem teve o lançamento de um
documentário incrível de alguns amigos
nossos que se chama eu maior
alguém conhece o projeto é o maior então
já está disponível na internet e é um
documentário brasileiro que fala sobre
autoconhecimento e busca da felicidade
muito obrigado